[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
today's video is going to be discussing
the five richest wizarding families in
the entire wizarding world but first
i've got a message for you guys from the
sponsor of today's video audible given
that the nature of this channel is harry
potter related i'm willing to bet that
there are some avid readers in here and
at least in my experience avid readers
usually also quite like audio books as
it allows them to digest their favorite
content while they're on the go if you
like being entertained while you're on
the go well you should keep listening
audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment all in one
place at audible you can find the
largest selection of audiobooks online
ranging from bestsellers and new
releases to celebrity memoirs languages
business motivation and more however
audible doesn't just offer audiobooks
there are thousands of other options in
other realms of audio as well including
podcasts guided wellness programs
theatrical performances comedy and more
in fact if you listen to every single
title available on audible right now
you'd be listening for three centuries
safe to say there's a reasonable
selection for me personally i listen to
all sorts of titles on audible most
recently i've been listening to the
percy jackson series and i've also been
brushing up on my greek mythology these
audiobooks allow me to stay entertained
while i'm driving working out grocery
shopping cooking and even writing
scripts you can also download them to
your phone and listen to them offline
anytime anywhere if this sounds good to
you then you're in luck because right
now audible is offering a 30-day free
trial to new members how do you sign up
all you have to do is go to audible.com
harry potter theory or text harry potter
theory to 500 500 as a member you'll
receive one credit each and every month
that you can use to redeem an audiobook
of your choice from audible's vast
collection the best part you get to keep
that book forever with the membership
you'll also have access to the popular
plus catalog which is filled with
thousands and thousands of ad-free
downloadable streamable pieces of
content that you can listen to all you
want no credits needed now you guys know
that i don't usually do ads on this
channel but when audible approached me i
made a massive exception that's because
audible is a service that i genuinely
use and believe in so again if you want
to give audible a try simply visit
audible.com harry potter theory or text
harry potter theory to 500 500 let's get
into the video the concepts of money and
status make appearances all over the
place in the harry potter story starting
right at the beginning in the very first
book we get draco boasting about his
family's wealth we get the impression
that perhaps ron and the weasleys aren't
doing quite so well to top it all off we
get to see harry's absolutely ridiculous
stack of gold inside vault 687 at
gringotts now provided that gringotts
handles the cash flow of nearly every
witch and wizard in the magical world
there must be some seriously immense
vaults full of gold kicking about
naturally my next question is who are
the top five richest witches and wizards
in the magical world let's get into it
number five gilderroy lockhart in 1982
british wizard gilderoy lockhart finally
graduated from hogwarts at which point
he began travelling all around the world
shortly after graduating he began to
build prominence as an author telling
his readers tales of his heroism and
illustrious magical ability these same
tales eventually brought him
considerable fame and as it turns out
fortune he was a dark wizard catcher a
dragon tamer a troll conqueror there was
a dark and powerful presence in the
world lockhart had vanquished it all by
himself the catch only he was there to
witness it after each and every time
that lockhart traveled he would return
home with a new book filled with
self-promotion heroism and extravagance
and it really left a positive impression
on the magical population he'd hold book
signings all over the magical world and
people love to be near lockhart in fact
you can go anywhere without seeing
lockhart's face or novel plastered all
along the insides of shop windows so
what's my point well lockhart became
filthy rich of course 4. harry potter
harry potter's wealth in the harry
potter story is certainly no secret and
we're exposed to it as early as a
philosopher's stone when we're first
introduced to vault 687 and gringotts
harry has piles and piles of gold and
his immense wealth is mentioned time and
time again throughout the harry potter
story but obviously since harry was just
a wee lad the money wasn't earned by him
but that certainly doesn't mean that
harry didn't have a plethora of wealthy
ancestors as it turns out the potter
family fortune started with the founding
paid truck of the family linfred of
tinchkom a revolutionary potioneer that
began to amass riches in the potter name
following him in the family business was
fleemont potter harry's grandfather with
all sorts of success of his own in short
harry had fat sacks of cash but his
fortune only grew after the death of
sirius black the black fortune was
immense and though sirius didn't have
access to all of it he certainly wasn't
skinned this meant that after his death
all of the money went to harry making
him one of the richest wizards in the
wizarding world
three the malfoys the mouthways always
seem to be praised as wealthy
individuals right that's correct but
interestingly as it turns out the
generational wealth that the malfoys
possess started with a wizard named
armand malfoy who arrived in britain
with william the conqueror having
rendered unknown shady and almost
certainly magical services to king
william the first malfoy was given a
prime piece of land in milkshake seized
from local landowners upon which his
descendants have lived for 10
consecutive centuries having land
ownership so early on in history gave
them a rather advantageous start and
this is reinforced by pottermore the
result is that they are one of the
richest wizarding families in britain
and it has been rumored for many years
though never proven that over the
centuries the family has dabbled
successfully in muggle currency and
assets
2. bellatrix and rodolfos lestrange the
old goblin obeyed pressing his palm to
the wood and to the door of the vault
melted away to reveal a cave-like
opening crammed from floor to ceiling
with golden coins and goblets silver
armor skins of strange creatures some
with long spines others with drooping
wings potions and jewelled the skull
still wearing its crown the above
passage of course describes the entrance
to the vault of none other than
belichick's to strange bellatrix
lestrange was a pure blood witch that
hailed from the black family and later
married into the pureblood le strange
family both the black family and her
strange families were wealthy in their
own right both stemming from the sacred
28 a directory of truly pureblood
families that still existed within the
wizarding world each family was
immensely wealthy with old money passing
down from generation to generation
bellatrix and her husband rodolfos ended
up with a large portion of the money
from both family trees and the
combination of these fortunes made them
some of the richest people in the entire
wizarding world overshadowing even the
malfoy's number one nicola flamel you
probably didn't guess this one nicola
flamel was a french scribe born in the
1300s in the city of pontois on a
day-to-day basis flamel worked as a
scribe and manuscript seller and ran two
shops offering these services in paris
flamel achieved a great deal of success
in his career and as a result became
quite wealthy however that's not where
the real money came from you see flamel
an alchemical master created an object
named the philosopher's stone which
among other abilities was able to turn
any metal into pure gold flamel of
course eventually dies but in the 666 or
670 odd years that he existed on the
planet i'm sure he had one or two
opportunities to turn objects into gold
in fact i'm willing to bet decapitalized
on it add that to the already immense
wealth that he and paranal held and well
we've got a winner what do you guys
think did i miss anyone would you
rearrange this list comment down below
until next time it does not do to dwell
on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you